it's a very ignorant way to thinkt you
know yeah and then they wouldn't want to
say that on my face cuz they wouldn't
want to smoke either
so you're limiting your potential your
Viewpoint and hurting us as a people
because we should be able to rise above
and play to the highest common
denominator and not dumb ourselves
[Applause]
[Music]
down
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect what's up guys I am
Thomas dope as whatever you want to call
me this is the dope as usual podcast I
am with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's
up guys guys today since season one
we've been talking about it maybe one
day today we have actor author and host
of Access Hollywood this is Mario Lopez
going on guys right onate we really
appreciate it pleasure spoked man sorry
I just want to get that out of there
this the most organic booking of all
time directly from an episode to social
media to just you responded and we
connected and we just a je you slid my
DMs right is that what happened not even
we just put out a video of Thomas
professing his love to you that's my guy
hey man that's my guy right there hey I
don't have a lot of examples growing up
dud I like it yeah um so I was going to
say this we uh I'm very explicit and
whatnot I wrote this as if I was like he
would not say this on access we've said
it many times like Mar Lopez wouldn't
say that I can't say that I gotta be
more professional so I actually wrote
these
questions like pretty cohesively more
prepared like we did Ted Talk I haven't
seen him so prepared since Ted Talk
exactly I respect that exactly wanted to
make sure we're we're we're getting
going you just posted today so I'm going
to get right into it blank slate yeah so
you're another game show and when does
it start yeah so for those who may not
be familiar Blank Slate is um a game
show that I'm hosting and producing uh
on the Game Show Network which is a
space I've always wanted to get into
because I love games I like board games
I like game shows and um that's why I
really like hosting to be honest is
because hosting is essentially being
yourself making sure everyone's having a
good time and you kind of keep the the
vibe going and so I feel like I'm the
same way whether I'm I'm hosting game
nights at my house you know having
carnadas just having people over or
doing a television show or Access
Hollywood or or my radio show um on with
Mario on ihart by the way what other
plugs Canon I get in no and then I got
it actually I got it and then blank
Slate's the new one um it just premiered
this last week and uh it's it did really
well it's doing really well which I'm
happy about but that's based on a
popular board game which is kind of like
a little like Match Game you have uh
fill-in the blank questions and you
partner up either with your homie or
wife or whatever the case maybe we've
seen all kinds of different pairings and
then we partner a comic with them and
you try to guess you see if you have the
right answers and if you have the right
answers they match up you get points
whoever most points wins and I love
doing it because there's no better
feeling than giving people money you
hook somebody El on money they're
excited it's just that's the best
feeling in the world job so yeah
question the behind the scenes I always
wonder for game shows like do they
really take that fridge home when I was
watching Bob bark like Is that real when
it comes to game shows too you have um
an attorney and a representative from
standards and practices to make sure
everything's on the up and up because
they don't want any like shady [__]
handun going on or they want make sure
like I'm hooking up all my you know my
homies or my I got over there and
they're trying to get the money to which
I Would by the way but so they got to
make sure that doesn't happen and uh
that everything's kind of um uh legit
but yeah so far so good man we're only
like a a week or two in so Blank Slate
awesome I saw the post right as we were
pulling up we got to talk about it right
off the bat but on with Mario Lopez how
long have you been doing that the radio
show you know I've been doing the radio
show I was just talking about it today
as a matter of fact 11 years oh wow 11
years we're going on 12 years
um this summer and thank God it's been
going really well uh we're in over 100
markets um it's nationally syndicated
through iHeart and um uh I have a lot of
fun it's essentially the same sort of
format that like CEST does on KISS FM
it's under the same umbrella and stuff
so we're talking about pop culture
current events music obviously then we
have uh a bunch of different guest stars
from the world of music or television
film they come in interview them and
have fun so I do that um in the morning
so I'm basically sequestered at
Universal Studios I do that in the
morning and then after that I do Access
Hollywood at night which is my nighttime
show then I do my daytime show access
daily after that every day those three
shows all right there and then and
that's not counting you know kids
coaching my son's wrestling team and
like training in the morning and then
doing other stuff or like Blank Slate or
like I'm getting ready I just had a uh
meeting before this I'm doing this
holiday film uh in Chicago we're going
in March um so you know all that stuff
like that so I like to kind of stay busy
was things like really messed up during
all the strikes that were going on well
we weren't able to to to do a I have
done I've done a holiday film like every
year for like the last uh seven eight
years or something like that um
sometimes to um cuz you you get older
that you start getting into that space
right like I'm a dad I got kids and
stuff so I'm doing Christmas movies
shows and all that all that so uh but
those are fun I like those and there's a
lot of fun and um we were in New Mexico
Nashville we've been kind of all over
the place but this we're uh coming up
we're going to be in Chicago which is a
lot of fun the radio was cool though
because it was funny cuz as it started
to grow um they wanted some sort of
female
presence and we tried out um different
female hosts to um so they can read all
like the the feminine uh products and
all whatever just to make it a little
bit more authentic so when they came in
the audience didn't like it because they
tried to give me a hard time and they
didn't like they were like protective
they didn't like it so my I had my wife
come in just kind of for fun and she
would like bust my chops and give me her
a time and the women loved it the
dynamic work they like they like like
I'm like well I don't be working my wife
every day that's not healthy for the
marriage so I said if we can shoot if we
can like pre-tape maybe for the week a
couple days a week so she only comes in
two days a week okay that I could roll
with her that I so yeah so now she does
it with me now but it sounds like she's
there every day I saw that you used to
have your daughter in segments when she
was she was younger right yeah I mean
hey everybody's got to pull their weight
to some my daughter's done a lot man
she's done a lot for both on the radio
and on um on Access Hollywood she's been
interviewing she's interviewed everyone
from like [__] to the Rock to to um my
gosh the cast of succession like
everybody knows it's just so she's she
just kind of got into she got into it
and one my son too he's done a lot of
stuff and she used to do that show Lena
Avalar and they kind I didn't like try
to get him into this business but they
kind of accidentally kind of fell into
it um my son's doing a little movie and
stuff this this summer you know they got
all their their activities right with
school and he wrestles and does
Jiu-Jitsu that's his main thing he loves
to Grapple and my daughter does like
gymnastics and competitive cheer and all
that my other little guy he's now
Wrestling doing Jiu-Jitsu straight dad
stuff
that's him all day every weekend four
games a week or a weekend a day actually
weekend give me all consum yeah I'm
trying to knock another one out my
wife's like hey you chill we were just
talking about this before before you
walked in right right right there you
shooting blanks or what got three kids
oh you already got three I got three I
got three as well I think nearly the
same as Aron is 15 16 okay good for you
um question being a Mexican and you uh
for all the stereotypes and whatnot you
waited a long time to have kids you did
not have kids in high school like my
entire town ex so exactly right did you
do you think that choice was beneficial
for you cuz I still don't have kids
because I'm just good I don't I don't
have a time yet I still got stuff to do
thank God I don't have any kids at least
I know that I think I know all the ones
I have right now at least they would
have popped up at this point I think at
some point no I think they would have
been yeah pretty much got the DI and
that's it um no I mean uh growing up I
was always um because I I'm from Chul
Vista so I'm the Bordertown right there
in right next to Deana and I'm a first
generation kid my parents San Diego
right yeah yeah right past San Diego
like there San cro CH Vista right there
in this Tiana and my parents are from um
place called kakoa and you know they're
very blue color folks my mom worked for
the uh phone company my dad worked for
the the city so they didn't know
anything about the the show business but
they wanted to keep me busy and out of
trouble cuz I was a hyper kid had
already broke my nose and I was already
like I I just it's funny cuz I just did
this um blood test for
some some health thing we've got to do
segment and they tell you everything
they took I don't know how many VES of
blood but anyway oh you're uh clinically
you got ADHD and you got this and I was
like well I could have told you that so
when I was young she put me in a bunch
of stuff to keep me busy and out of
trouble cuz you could have gotten a lot
of stuff so uh especially down where I
was growing up so I was like the only
dancing wrestling karate theater kid
that I knew so every day I had a uh she
been on the schedule class she jamack
the schedule and workers I didn't get
any any kind of real trouble other than
talking too much in class stupid stuff
like that but I didn't get any real
trouble so I was I was busy and I think
being busy and then I couldn't even kick
back at home like my dad if I he saw me
chilling on the couch get up and do
something and then he put me to put me
to work I dig a ditch and the ditch
didn't even me to be
D just wanted just hey and if a friend
of mine spend the night he put their ass
to work too so you could nobody want to
kick in my house cuz he put everybody
had to put to work so I think since I
was a little kid I always had like a
strong work ethic because of my dad and
um that for the most part uh wanted me
to I I was ambitious so I didn't um I
didn't have I mean don't get me wrong I
like girls but I I was I was trying to
trying to be cognizant of not knocking
anyone up your question oh yeah yeah the
the best response a three minute try not
knock nobody yeah yeah so did they have
you out like auditioning too what was
that did they have you go into like
auditions and stuff oh so yeah yeah so
she got me involved in a bunch of
different things and then somebody came
up to my mom and said I think they saw
me like at a player Dancing or something
and she said hey you ever thought about
getting them into like print work my mom
was like what's that and that's you know
when you see magazines and you see like
little kids and you know the target
stuff yeah exactly Target what happened
and she's like no but you know he reads
well and he's not shy you know you
little small one I was like I was like
nine I was like n so you know so you
know I was I was always like reading I
didn't necessarily comprehend it but I
could read an early age and then and I
wasn't shy I always like was kind of
like outgoing so she's like yeah you
know you know shut up why not so then
she signed with that local agent and
then I kind of got into it from there
she's like hey M you want to do this I
was like yeah all right and then I kind
of did everything my mom wanted me to do
anyway and then um that agent started
having started kind of getting bigger
and having auditions in LA and then my
mom was like do you want to do this I
was like all right and then she started
taking me on auditions and so you know
everything that I am or have or willever
be is I owe it to my mom and well my dad
too cuz you know Chul Vista that takes
you about 2 and a half hours almost 3
hours to drive up here for like a 5
minute audition you got to drive back
they did that all the time and my dad um
when he would take me and sometimes even
when I would work and stuff or if I had
a couple back to back in the day we
stayed at all the ghetto ass hotels
right there in Sunset were like 40 bucks
and I remember I was like years old I
used to see like um pimps beating up
there chicks right there and first time
I saw nak a chick too like her dress
went up and I was like oh damn and so uh
cuz I didn't care I was with my dad so I
felt safe but um um that so they just
you know they they got me into it and uh
once I got into it then I kind of fell
in love with it I wasn't one of those
little kids like I want to be on TV I
was never that kid I was happy doing
whatever um but once they got once they
did get me into it and I'm like you get
paid for this oh you give money what oh
all right well this beats like a real
job so then I decided to kind of stick
with it and that's how it is but I
didn't care whether I was doing it or
whether I wasn't so that maybe that
attitude kind of helped in those
auditions where did like acting uh rank
next to sports at that time so well I
always loved wrestling and I always
loved Sports so that was probably more
my passion more than anything but then I
always figured okay well this is very
unpredictable this line of work you
don't know when your next gig may come
and so I might as well stick with it
until um I can I can help my parents out
I can put money away for college and all
that stuff um and then I just kind of
kept getting busy and then next thing
you know I was out of high school school
and I was like still working so I was
like all right I'll get to it later and
then uh I never got to for St yeah PRI a
priority thing like I love sports but
this is going to pay me yeah yeah yeah
exactly and then you know I was because
my growing up I thought okay I'll help
my parents make enough money to get into
college and then I'll figure out what
I'm going to do but I was fortunate
enough to kind of just keep working yeah
so uh Kids Incorporated yeah that was
was that your first bigger thing like
when you go to school like hey I saw you
on TV no the first thing I did is a big
thing called uh AKA Pablo when I was 10
was on ABC that's old school you don't
you don't remember that [__] that sh was
too you're too young you remember that
okay you're my age all right then we're
the same age okay remember yeah Paul Rod
okay very good Paul Rod that was a
Norman leer show a Paul Rodriguez show
Paul well Norman Le the legendary Norman
rest in peace he um you know he produced
on the family Jefferson's Good Times all
one day at a time all these iconic so he
did uh a show called AK Pablo that was
based on Paul Rodriguez a young PA
Rodriguez the time of comic but uh man I
had every like stereotype in there like
30 people living in one
house and I was one of the little
cousins Tomas Delgato that was my name
and uh and yeah that was a big deal we
did 13 episodes then got canceled
because our people were like like that
[__] was too stereotypical to over the
top um and then uh but that was like my
first thing and I remember I was
shooting next to like um Silver Spoons
with Ricky Schroeder and uh Different
Strokes with Gary Coleman
yeah and then like the dud from my
noodle were there all the time so I was
like tripping out as a little kid and
that was right here at Universal Studios
like where I work right now so that was
like that was the first thing I did and
then after that I got Kids Incorporated
which was like The Mickey Mouse Club if
you're not familiar with exactly what I
said Micky Mouse everybody really sang
and danced and played the instruments
and I played the drums and I danced
right there and that was cool cuz to
this day it's probably the hardest job I
ever got we had to learn three dances
and I don't know how many songs a week
um I did that for what 3 four years and
uh like Fergie Stacy Ferguson was on
that show this is like Middle School no
I was 10 bro oh you fourth fifth grade I
was yeah so I was 10 so then um she was
on that
Martia Sean Patterson Jennifer Love hu
like they had like a lot of good people
hey there's a Mickey it is a Mickey
Mouse club before before it yeah yeah
yeah so from Kids Incorporated how do
you one of my favorite movies ever how
do you get into the most gangster movie
of all time Colors oh colors you know
it's was a trip about colors so we did
that what was that 1988 8788 Dennis
Hopper was the director and that was
with Robert Duval and Shawn pan I was
supposed to be um Felipe's brother if
you remember the one threw the rocks at
the car the one threw the rocks at the
car but I was too tall to play opposite
Trinidad Silva my brother for some
reason I was like small guy yes he's a
little guy and uh cuz I was like a tall
skinny kid and then um I was like oh
damn cuz uh cuz like I had read the SC I
was like oh this this be pretty badass
be but the director ended up like kind
of liking hey you know what but I want
you to be in it anyway you could be like
felipa's friend hold hold this Uzi and I
said all right so it came out now
remember Shawn pen cuz at the time Shawn
pen was married to Madonna and she used
to come to the set so I see that and we
had a lot of like everybody like we had
a lot of real like real [__] essays
come out right there dudes from like
white fence 18th Street they even jacked
some of the camera equipment remember we
had to shut down for a little bit the
Jack equ I'll never forget that when we
shot that right here in La yeah I
remember Ice T when he came down and did
the to the song he did I am a nightmare
walking psychopath I remember that so
yeah it was dope once in a while s comes
on I was like oh damn that [__] still
holds up still dope it's still kind of
dope it holds no Cheetos on it so yeah
so I trip out when they play oh right he
was the crib that's right so was Damon
Williams he's over tweaking with the
bear there was a lot of stars yeah
you're right lot of dudes in that I just
remember I was a kid I'm like all right
Dad I'll watch he Slaters that's him
yeah I was 8 what was that so I was uh
13 1 13 like 13 almost 14 something like
that damn by the Bell already kicked off
if you're no no no a couple years later
right and that's when The Big Break
comes AC Slater that's when I did that
say by the Bell did that like before
that though then I was like on the
Golden Girls and I did a bunch of
different shows I did a bu that's right
you yes right I did a commercials Golden
Girls one episode but I worked with B
Arthur who played Dorothy I did like
three shows with her um you know Pilots
are like show and they don't uh come to
fruition
like you know then the they don't come
to fruition but they they do a show and
then they wait to see if it's going to
come to series but I did like three um
with her and then Whit Thomas who were
the producers they asked me to come and
uh yeah I played an legal alien and they
deported my ass yeah I did but I was a
Cuban kid and it was kind of like I was
like I was like Ellen Gonzalez no cuz it
took place in Miami oh yeah oh so they
had to makeb they had to Miami you're
Brown yeah yeah and then it was like and
then ironically like that was like the
real life thing like my character when I
was a kid man that was I remember that
so that but that was before so yeah so
no that was cool so yeah the old and
girls and we did a bu you know little
movies in the say by the Bell was like
89 right before 90 but that was a
Saturday morning show that was like it
was just a Saturday morning show it
wasn't a like it didn't start so it was
popular for Saturday mornings I remember
when we beat Bugs Bunny in the ratings
that was a big deal but then when it um
when it got into
syndication that's when it uh that's
when it really took off and they started
playing it dude that [__] was 35 years
ago now yep yeah no I'm old so that sh
was 35 years ago still and it's still on
um still holds up dude that was funny
cuz that's supposed to be for little
kids like little kids Saturday morning
yeah Saturday break in the fourth wall
is that why it was more kidish it was
supposed to be real kidish well they did
that cuz of fer berer remember like get
go home mol in the middle stole that
from Z Morris so exactly so that was for
little kids and then it Tri me out that
like other people that weren't little
kids were liking it um I mean the girls
were fine so maybe that was a maybe that
was a big reason and stuff but um like
it was kind of already done when it
started taking off in syndication like
you weren't really so active yeah we
weren't already it was but then we went
back and we did like the College Years
and then we did like a few movies and
stuff but it was all Saturday morning
and so it's funny cuz so everybody was
like Hey dude that shit's been on for
all that talk you must you must be
loaded in this and I dude I didn't make
we didn't make [__] we didn't make any
Carly money on that stuff we making like
$1,500 which is a lot for a 15-year-old
kid wait wait mind you I'll save by the
bill save by the bill that's it that's
it so we didn't so $1,500 so trip out on
this and then my parents like I told you
know Blue Collar so then we still had to
come up here get an apartment or my
dad's get we get a hotel we were staying
and then by the time you know I wasn't
really I was kind of almost breaking
even but my parents wanted to do it just
cuz obviously the experience and I get
the to have something on the resume and
do all that so no I didn't make any
money we didn't make any money the whole
time went up a little bit I think I got
up to like 3500 you know what I'm saying
but it wasn't like friends you know what
I'm saying we making no friends kind of
money or anything like that so it wasn't
like that so that's why people always
that you know not [__] I wish that
wasn't the case but I'm grateful and
appreciative that I did it but um we
were young and um a lot of the time and
then it was just Saturday morning was
then the situation was what it was and I
still want to sign up for it so is it
standard like we all was that was the
problem is is that was wasn't a problem
but just the fact of the matter is that
it was the first of its kind it was the
first
liveaction show in sitcom on Saturday
morning so like I said they were paying
cartoon money it wasn't like Disney
Channel now or Nickelodeon or you right
where they got a t they didn't have that
where they got a ton of shows and just
lineup and they get paid kind of real
money wasn't that so yeah I just watched
it on Loop they just played it in bricks
when I was a kid I just watched it till
it was done yeah so that was a that's a
deal right there I did not realize that
um one question I didn't I was a kid but
I didn't realize that Slater doesn't
speak Spanish well he wasn't Mexican I'm
get everybody comes up to me you'll
speak Spanish man I need to learn
Spanish from that [__] but as a brown
dude on TV that can speak Spanish in
real life I don't speak Spanish I'm the
only person in my family that does it
nobody taught me it's not my fault don't
Tau me my mom's
Jewish
anyway as a Spanish speaker because you
know Mexicans when you go oh SP no like
ah yeah that's what I get got you every
time like oh got you got you too no but
he wasn't here's the irony cuz I'm like
100% Mexican however a lot of the roles
I played they weren't Mexican and they
just kind of casted blindly Brown he was
supposed to be my character was supposed
to be Italian and he was supposed to be
like Vinnie Barberino Welcome Back
Cotter you know what I mean later on
they decided oh you know what we never
really established ethnicity and then
when I was in college I discovered that
my last name was uh had a z in it forgot
what it was Sanchez or something like
that and then uh and then all of a
sudden I'm like a Mexican but the whole
time growing up the whole time the show
was supposed to be Italian it's eded in
the I had no idea I just saw Brown guy
like yeah my dad look like my dad with a
good hair yeah yeah yeah I tried to find
the picture but my grandma she couldn't
she doesn't how to use is that why they
had the Jericho going or is that just no
that was say my mom she used to like
your mom did that for you my mom did
that [__] for me everybody back in the
day used to think they were um
hairdressers so she just did that and I
just had the soow like I said dude I
just did everything my mom did my mom
said that your mom should be proud that
she St started a trend with young
Mexican kids rocking the Jerry girl it's
coming back I don't see a lot of kids
now mullets the whole thing it's crazy
in Texas when I went to every Brown kid
had it it's crazy they're rocking that
or Edgars so yeah the Edgar Ed crazy
that's where Ralph bar are no Ralph bar
no no Edgar is basically a bull cut
straight across and they get they kind
of get like Jersey Shore with it oh okay
well there's like different iterations
of it but yeah I'm not going to rock
that no no I never like that I can't um
I have a question as a fan and for all
the fans out there if I don't ask is
there any untold stories or wild stories
with the Bayside crew that no one's ever
heard no I mean I've gotten asked a lot
through throughout the years it really
wasn't we were pretty like I mean we
were actual I think one of the reasons
why it resonated with kids is we were
actual kids playing the show a lot of
times before that you have like people
in their 30s playing School K we were
actually 15 playing 15y olds so I think
that's one of the reasons and because of
that we always had our parents right
there so you can't have really we had to
have our parents or Guardians so they
couldn't have really too many
Shenanigans cuz you know you got Mom
right there dad looking over so you know
they had us like on a tight leash and
teachers social workers everybody's like
has an eye on you so you couldn't really
like wild out not on set I mean I was
wild they're not offset but not onet all
right see that was that was just a
question all right um so on to my next
uh question from you used to do extra
yeah and then access Hollywood those are
in studios and I want to know for
America's Best Dance Crew in front of a
live audience now this is is this the
first time you're hosting in front of a
massive crowd um continuous I got into
hosting when I was like 18 I did a show
called name your adventure and that's
when I kind of fell in love with it um I
did that for a few seasons then I kind
of did the male version of The View
called the other half with Dick Clark we
did that for three seasons and then that
and then 91 we debuted on 911 which is
crazy bad timing talk about bad timing
and we still managed to go a couple
Seasons but we it was hard to kind of
recover and after obviously it changed
the world and all that so I had hosted
in front of a live audience a lot um
this is probably like your generation
for the ABDC America's Best Dance Crew
which I had a lot of fun um uh doing and
you know when I go to Vegas and I see
the jabawaki I was like hey that's cool
man I'm glad to see them do well and
stuff so you're the you're the one that
introduced them to the world yeah now
they have the what is it uh what is it
called residency right residency yeah
it's pretty it's pretty wild man I mean
when I was in high school everybody had
a mask
and thought they could pop unlock yeah
they're from San Diego originally are
they really I had no idea yeah oh okay
so was there a moment where you're like
I'm going to stop trying to pursue
acting and start just trying to like be
a presenter and a host well when I got
out
of when I got out of high school I still
I think I was still doing Save By the
Bell for another year or two um and then
I was like why like my dad said I don't
want to get a real job I want to keep
kind of trying to do this but then you
come into the point where people sort of
stereotype you and they see you in a
certain way and then you're the kid from
the high school show so it's hard for
them to kind of I mean that's like a
real thing it's hard for them to typ
cast yeah they typ cast you it's hard
for them to see you outside of that so I
said to myself well I don't want to just
be um pigeon hold and and wait for the
phone to ring and just rely on uh on
someone's um opinion of me to to to see
if they believe me in a certain role
what have you so I said I I don't want
to just act I said I there are no rules
so I want to get into hosting I like
hosting so I started leaning into that
did Broadway I want to start getting
doing plays started doing that um
started writing started getting into
like author so I just said I want to
kind of try to fire on all cylinders so
if I'm not doing this I'll do that and
if I'm not doing this I'll do that so
I've always kind of like I said had that
Hustler mentality to try to kind of stay
busy and again thank God I haven't had
had a real job my dad because it's fun
so that was my Approach and I look at
Kids now and I see how so many kids are
are entrepreneurs and little capitalists
in the way they've essentially taken
advantage of YouTube and having a
platform and making real money doing all
this and I'm like damn if that [__] was
around when I was a kid I would have
crushed that [__] cuz I I was always
like a hustler and I would have been all
over that and I would have really leaned
into that to do that and so um I think
it's the best time in history if you're
a young person wanting to get into his
business because you don't have to wait
around for the phone to ring you can
create your own content
you can create your own BR as as much as
you're willing to work and bust your ass
you can put yourself out there and
really serve an audience and monetize it
so that's what I think is great now
about now you can obviously do the
traditional and try to root and get an
agent do all that but now there's so
many different platforms I wish they had
that when I was a kid but they didn't
but I tried to do as much as I can
without those sort of platforms so
that's why I got into hosting and doing
all that other stuff yeah yeah like we
said we start I started off in my house
with a grow room there you go exactly
you guys are a good example exactly oh
before this just me doing YouTube for
years that's how I got the fall and
that's when we started the show right
it's just it was a grow light from a
grow room the phone like it's just as
much as you want to work exactly as much
as you want to work edit 20 hours who
cares I'll edit all my own stuff and it
took 8 to 10 years but it worked and I
think that's what it takes you always
see the dude that's 30 like what were
you doing for 10 years I've been working
for 10 years trying to get this off the
ground right so yeah it's not an
overnight you have your own fan base
it's not just like attached to like a
network that could just go away at some
point so person so it's no I think like
right now it's better than ever and um
again you guys are a case in point so
thank you appreciate that hey what's up
guys just taking a moment to talk about
one of our sponsors and this is raw
papers as you know raw is the official
rolling paper of the dope as usual
podcast so before we get started shout
out to Raw thank you so much for
supporting the show but guys I want to
get into this right here I know you're
staring at it this is brand new this is
insane it's very rare if you can get
your hands on it and you try it please
let me know what you think 20 to 30%
thinner Josh sent it to me the other day
and I asked him what is the difference
he he said it's the thinnest rolling
paper you've ever seen you can't lick it
too much because you will take the glue
right off he said this is for the
experienced roller The Connoisseur this
is to taste what you're smoking 100%
this is just the vessel and it's the
thinnest vessel you can possibly have
coolest looking pack I've seen in a long
time my first love was the king size raw
and then it was Organics and then it's
the blacks and now it's these so once
again if you get your hands on these
please send us a comment let us know how
you liked them so once again thank you
guys so much for supporting raw thank
you to Raw for supporting our podcast
the official rolling paper with the dope
as usual podcast thank you guys so much
for watching as always thank you for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode my cousin JoJo he
just won uh state champ wrestling
recently California out of mered out of
Merced College first person to ever win
state from our from our uh our town
which is awesome so my dad me I wrestled
everything like like I said as Slater I
wrestle so um my question is when you
were younger how serious were you really
taking this as a wrestling taking the
wrestling yes because I've seen the
picture I've seen the TR like were you
that kid that like oh it's that Mario
Lopez from that [__] I didn't know that
kid his name was Randy tet and when he
walked in go what weight class he going
to be in he's going to school everybody
to do that between driving back and
forth from basically Mexico and la like
your whole childhood is insane yeah yeah
no that's why again man I owe everything
to my parents and um yeah no I was
serious about it but I was busy and I
had other activities but I was busy um
but I was serious and uh and you know
fortunately I still managed to do pretty
well and I loved it um and I think it it
implemented a lot of the attributes that
I have the thing about wrestling that I
always loved because I tried to play
team sports too I was like baseball and
I was like football but when you have an
audition or a show and you have to
bounce you can't do that to your team
it's not fair to them right because you
need to have that cohesiveness and the
chemistry going on but when you're in an
individual sport even though there's
team element all you got to do is beat
the guy out in your weight class and I
like that plus I didn't like to rely on
anyone else for My Success if I'm going
to lose it's going to be my fault but
I'm going to win it's going to be
because of me so I like it so I won I
got all the glory and I got the
attention and I wanted to be out there
and the thing about wrestling too is
you're completely sort of vulnerable and
naked in the sense that hey there's no
backup there's no one coming off the
bench it's just you and another man
Pier's form of sport I'm going to try to
kick your ass you're going try to kick
mine and you learn to be physically
tough mentally tough you know a problem
solve M you know like I tell my boys if
youve wrestled everything else in life
is easy MH it's probably I mean I played
football played everything it's the
hardest thing conditioning all every
rolling everything is just the it's the
most strenuous thing you could think of
two minutes and I'm done it's like
playing a football game yeah no would
you say like as far as MMA goes in the
UFC is wrestling and grappling the
strongest attribute you can have versus
like all the different like facets of
MMA I would say it's the best foundation
you obviously need to be comfortable
and familiar and and try to get as much
training as you can in all aspects but
if you look at the just the champions in
um in history even now John Jones um
Henry cejudo and uh khabib and the list
goes on and on they were all wrestlers
and then they learned how to strike and
then they learned jiujitsu and then I
think having that as a foundation
because it's very aggressive too it's
you
you naturally have to attack yeah so
it's you're not being passive at all so
I I would maybe I'm bias but I would say
yes and I think a lot of those guys
would agree too and you know it's still
in me like I I train this morning like I
do
jiujitsu um I even compete once in a
while it's fun like you know try to show
my kids like hey you know you're never
too old to set goals for yourself the
picture you with that giant black eye
and then you're on camera later that day
is insane no I know and I broke this
finger earlier and uh you know and so
they don't it's kind of frowned upon you
know and uh uh at work but I had
transition like I still box cuz I was
boxing a lot too cuz I into that my
grandfather used to do that and I used
to do smoke ERS which are like three
round fights over wild Freddy roach wild
Club um and I still do that I'm going
Spar tomorrow as a matter of fact I said
I said I would I said I was so slowed
down my wife wanted me to slowed down
but I'm like ah makes me feel alive face
all the time yeah no I got 16 gloves and
I got headgear we're not but still I
mean still you still get lock but I I
jack myself up there that's a more
explosive sport so I torn my rotator
cuff I've torn my achilles I've torn my
biceps you get surgery for that yeah
fool this whole thing came off what you
talking about the whole thing all these
I had to get major surgeries you know
broke my fingers and all that and I'm
like I don't know when my body's
completely broken down and de cpit then
I'll start playing golf but no it makes
me feel young makes me feel alive um you
know I don't want to show my boys how
many of those were Jiu-Jitsu uh injuries
none none I mean I got like the
Jiu-Jitsu one just the fingers just you
get your fingers a little mangled and
stuff and you know some black eyes and
all that but the the serious injuries
are uh always been boxing so one thing I
always thought of is with you really
wrestling in high school and then I
watched Say by the Bell this morning
came am I wrestling Aus later what is
happening yeah everybody everybody went
extra hard on me they had um but um but
I mean I didn't care so I just you know
kind I just kind of did my own thing you
know and now it's funny cuz cuz now they
go extra hard on my boys cuz you know
cuz now it's like oh Mario Lopez is kids
you know I see little guys right make
sure you try you know what I mean but my
boys they they don't they don't trip you
know cuz they want to be able to say you
know we kick Mar Lo's kids ass you know
but my but fortunately they're good
my little son's like a stud and uh and
he doesn't pay attention he doesn't know
cuz he's he's 10 right so he doesn't see
like I see the parents talking and stuff
so I that but I don't care so I told him
hey you be out there and you know you go
out there and you kick ass you be
aggressive you do what you got to do and
um so I'm raising my boys that way and
uh they're going to CU they're going to
get attention no matter what anyway
right so they might as well be tough
might good be tough and be good so yeah
love that and your your youngest son is
he wrestling too he's wrestling too he's
he's only four he's wrestling too my
other boy wrestles he does all freestyle
Greco collegia does Jiu-Jitsu noi G does
it all so damn yeah no he's yeah no he's
a little beast so you know um he's 10
he's 10 he's a cute little kid so you
know um he's probably going to get mess
with her that but so I got to make sure
uh he take care of himself do you get up
at like 4:30 in the morning no I get up
at 600 I get up at 6 and then had
sometimes I get up a little bit earlier
but um usually about six and so
typically I'll get up I'll get all help
get the kids ready I'll leave with them
just a little bit have a little coffee
and then I go train I'll either do
Jiu-Jitsu or box or do whatever or I'm
Physical Therapy nursing an injury and
then um and then after that then I go do
the radio show then I go do Access
Hollywood then I do access daily
sometimes after that I'll go shoot black
slate or do whatever or I'll come talk
to you
fools well I mean I went to the doctor
this morning I'm try I'm trying I'm
trying how many times we say like we
just got to get up like American Psycho
like iush it was like our number one fan
question basically like what's his tip
what's his secret to like looking so
good after so long basically like how
does he not age thanks no um know it's
funny man I don't know like people you
ask every day I I got some oily ass skin
it's like you put a fried piece of
chicken on my face and I got some oily
ass skin they say that I was I don't
know I always like to say though um I
drink a lot of tequila so uh it's like a
bombing flu it you oh no believe me I'll
get oh KAS like I got my own but I don't
discriminate oh yeah you do you have
your own uh your own tequila what's it
called uh Kasa Mexico it's really good
too we just came out with a crystallo oh
I should have brought some dude oh dude
it on the show man yeah yeah yeah for
sure so but it's really good too so
there's no magic secret you just take
care of yourself get I mean I I mean
well [__] I drink and smoke and I like
to eat a lot and you know I don't it's
not like I'm doing any you know what I
mean I exercise but that's just cuz I
like I'm hyper but um other than not
really I like to eat everything I mean I
don't know I just got just lucky I think
I don't know no that was lit one of my
questions cuz people ask me why do you
look 22 still like is the weed in
smiling and I have no and I have no kids
I think is what like keeps it going cuz
that was my question yeah I think being
happy too I mean I feel very I feel very
blessed and you know I got great wife
and great kids and you know I don't take
it for granted so I think just being
happy probably helps too cuz it's been
it's been part of you when Marlo how do
you st cuz I remember you told Christian
Troy when you're when you're having
breakfast at the at the restaurant I'm
running by you doing my 10 miles in the
morning when you play the doctor in Nip
Tuck oh Nip Tuck exactly y I remember
that I was 14 I watch my I got to get
that in shape yeah yeah yeah no no I
mean I do make it a point to like um try
to exercise um at least six days a week
just CU I want to U but I don't lift
anymore I don't lift weights or anything
anymore just cuz I'm always I need like
something more
to um because it gets boring to be
honest with you it gets boring get a
little monotonous and just doing the
machines doing the workouts I want to I
like to make makes me think so Jiu-Jitsu
is like is like um chess but physical
chess so you're always problem solving
this and then boxing too you're always
kind of problem solving you're figuring
stuff out and keeps you on point so that
keeps me I think kind of motivated those
one of my questions like body body
weight workouts versus like weight
training you think that they can be
comparable no I yeah they can and
they're all great and they're all help I
always tell people what whatever makes
you move Whatever Gets you out of bed
whatever makes you move whatever you're
going to be consistent with and whatever
makes you break a sweat do that but just
for me it got a little monotonous a
little after a while and so I like to
kind of mix it up and focus on those
other things see how big some those
inmates are man that's all body weight
exactly stepdad was a monster you know
what I'm saying so body weight it does
work you can do it without like the
squat rack yeah for sure um so nearly 40
years now in this industry yeah do you
uh contributed to work ethic behind the
scenes input or do you just this is what
you love to do I mean I they little all
of the above I mean I think work ethic
not
limiting limiting myself into um a hole
a hole and and just being put in a
certain position I think just kind of
keeping my options open trying to create
opportunities for myself taking that
YouTube mentality yeah right um and like
I said whether it's um I'm singing and
dancing or I'm I'm hosting something
whether I'm acting or whatever the case
may be I I just kind of try to keep my
hands in a bunch of different buckets
and um and stay uh stay as busy as I can
you know when I got the opport to work
with Dick Clark um he became a friend
and he had a big influence on me too and
he's like you got to look at yourself
Mario um as a brand and I think you
should lean into the hosting because
acting is here is to other people's
discretion but when you look at yourself
as a brand then you can be in your
someone's living room every day for the
rest of your life and I said to myself a
light bubble I'm like okay that's it I
want to be the Latino Dick Clark I want
to be able to be on I want to be in your
family room for the next uh you know 50
years no we said
trying to beat Jimmy Kimmel man I just
want to take a spot when I'm older what
we said so one of my questions is uh
well I'm super explicit I'm trying to
tone it down we had fluffy here he goes
bro you got That's my boy we're working
on a project together really yeah we had
it here recently he's like my key say
I'm I'm clean I used to be filthy but
you can't be in everyone's home and just
drop an F bombs on exact so what is your
advice cuz you just said I'm trying to
be the Latino CL that's well thank you
and I didn't mean to interrupt you but
that's exactly it I want to appeal to
like everyone like I don't know who
those fools were they were talking about
they questioning me if I was Mexican and
stuff yeah because I was like
[__] I grew upana and like you
know what I mean I'm probably no more
Spanish than your ass you don't even
speak so I don't know those guys were
but it bothers me because they unless
you're like you know they think that
you're not and that is so awful it
limits you it's ignorant and you want to
be able to appear in everyone's home
that's why when people ask me my
political affilation or why don't you
talk about this one you like hey man I
don't want to Al I don't want to
alienate anyone I don't want to give
anyone the reason to change the channel
because they don't like my viewpoint you
know what I'm in the people business I
want everybody to be like hey you know
what I don't know how Mario thinks and I
like that and people have told me that
before so I want to be cool with
everyone now like I'm vocal about my
faith I'm a proud Catholic guy and I
know they say you're not supposed to
talk about religion but God wants you to
I don't go talk about it but if I asked
about it I will respond and I am proud
of that but when it comes to politics
I'm like no no no no and cuses that's
all you player you do what you think is
best for you you do what you think is
your for your family who am I to tell
you anyway I think a lot of the actors
is like they high horse and why am I
going listen to you you know what I mean
so you do what you best as year for I
take care of my family I want to do
what's best for my kids I try to give
back to my community I was a kid growing
up in the boys club I get back to the
girls and boys clubs proud to say we've
raised millions of dollars um in in
doing that and I think if more people
took care of their home first and their
Community we'd be much better off as a
society all these virtue signalers and
trying all that I ain't about that life
mhm well put man yeah that was beauti
that's how I'm just trying to be with
everybody why do I have to I just found
out what a republican Democrat was
recently so I just don't care MH like
because like they could love you forever
and go oh he's a republic I'm Chang I
don't like Mar Lopez anymore that's why
I'm just you know exactly I'm just like
hey what you do you yeah our show has
the same approach like we're a fun place
to hang out on Mondays yeah so we'll
have people in here like oh they're
going through some drama in the news
like I'm not going to talk about that
yeah I'm trying to get them to leave
going that was fun I don't feel stressed
out at all good at that's the whole
point of the show we're not Jerry spring
like bring out your dad you know we're
not going to do that to anybody well you
know it's funny you say that cuz when
I'm doing interviews too I always I
don't ever want to be that salacious guy
or like that oh got your moment because
then people that's going to get around
people are going to know and then I
think when you just have that
conversation and you're a good listener
and you kind of follow up on what they
say they end up divulging more than what
they want anyway every sing and they end
up kind of giving more and you end up
getting like these sound bites and all
that and N wasn't even intending in
going there but they went there cuz they
felt comfortable yep because you have
that certain approach had that happen in
the most giant way last episode this
kind of leads into one of my questions
we had actor uh Jake Johnson on here
last episode yeah we had this clip oh I
saw that clip that his mom sent him or
the dude like he was going to he was he
shot up a place or was it no no a plane
went down or something no he was in
school and his mom's like you're not
going to school tomorrow I have a bad
feeling she's like all right I won't and
then some lady came and shot up a class
yeah they shot up yeah exactly that's in
two days this clip's gotten like 15
million views Instagram and Tik Tok
remember and the conversation is so like
I didn't realize so divided the idea of
intuition and premonition and a mother's
instinct and all is all we've never had
a post go like have this much
Conversation Over It where do you stand
on like Intuition or like the
supernatural superstitious kind of
things well I'm I'm I'm I'm a little bit
of a believer in this sense so when I
was a kid when I was a baby I was born
eight and a half pounds right and
then
for some reason um I started losing a
lot of weight like I got down to like
three and a half pounds or four or
something like that like my stomach
wasn't really formed they thought I was
going to die long story short the priest
came and blessed me and thought I was
going to die my dad took me out of the
hospital took me to like this bruha like
it's like a wisht doctor out by um inada
uh South the border and she like whipped
up some [__] with goats milk and seaweed
and Kelvin [__] and started to say hey
put this in his thing and uh feed him
back up and not that [__] worked but
he'll be on AIS Hollywood that [__] well
I survived and then I got mad fat and
then I was like went from nothing and I
got you're seeing baby pictures of me I
look like [__] Buddha dude well your
your profile picture right Google this
right here better was a f h at one point
no so Dad it's I was a fat baby hey man
I'll take what I
hear so yeah then and so after that I
I'm a big belie well at least I'm a
believer of alternative medicine cuz it
worked I'm a I'm a I'm a living uh they
working out like a miracle basically
like wow he just saved his life so was
basically yeah didn't it happen this
where time with be real look at my arms
right there lookat arm oh damn y giant
baby oh fat then I got mad fat def have
more rules than I do Jesus Christ did
you see his arms yeah look right there y
baby arms are the funniest thing to look
at dud my mom my mom said she used to
have to like spread my and clean in
between there they get all moisty mad
moisty right there yeah dude oh look at
this one look like a baby P Pablo
Escobar right there the shirt the shirt
I would rock right that [__] is great
yeah right yeah you do look like a
little drug dealer I have a baby pinky
ring and a bracelet like it's a real
Mexican you're Mexican where's your gold
Shain yeah I had one okay just Mak sure
one of them fat
rolls um so speaking of another thing U
my grandpa every save everything save
every my grandpa was born in Mexico on
the streets so he's that guy came here
built everything so your first check you
ever got that you were doing stuff and I
know they're like don't spend it on
anything but I know you went out like I
I've worked for 12 years I'm going to
buy something I just wanted to know
from the culture of hey save everything
and you know you're young you're doing
things like I'm I'm making money what is
the first thing you actually did for
yourself I just wanted I I always
thought of that so when you don't have
money growing up like I did and you
start making money you can go two ways
either you get real flossy and you start
buying all kinds of [__] you don't need
you're trying to putting it out there or
you save it and you're like oh [__] this
could go away at any moment yeah and I
don't know if I'm ever going to be able
to make this money again that was me I'd
be saving everything and I've always had
like that kind of frugal mentality I
mean my dad was like that my dad you
walk around and shut up all the lights
and
[__] I do so no I'm that way you know
what I'm saying so you got to grow up
that way so that it just I was like damn
I turned into him but um I never really
I mean I don't really buy anything
Splash wise like like any Splash think a
21-year-old Mario Lopez the stupidest
investment I made the stupidest thing I
did but I had a damn good time I was 19
and I invested in a club in Tijuana oh
on Revolution and what was it sex revolu
it was on Revolution um you ever been
down there like with all the bars and
stuff I've been down there but underage
so I was just my grandma everybody's
underage what you mean everybody's like
yeah I was like 17 Dr is 18 but we
started going down like 15 16 so bad
when I think about it now it's crazy but
uh and then a buddy of mine Tommy Corona
we we bought a club a bar club in
Tijuana and we had fun but uh worst
investment ever worst and best ever it's
the only time like I spent money um that
was uh not wise how long did that last
for [__] I we had it like I think like
three years us you know what it was a
fun run hey you can't put a price t on a
good time no man all the memories yeah
um so I have one more question for you
know what go go V it Marty I have at the
end uh so one of the main we ran a lot
of fan questions and one of there's like
top three that were like overwhelming is
there any any good uh dust and Diamond
like stories that people might not know
from behind the scenes any good Destin
Diamond stories you know he was a few
years younger than us M right I think we
were like when we were all 15 he was 12
oh you serious yeah or 13 maybe just two
but he was young enough to like where
you didn't want to really kick it you
know what I'm saying you that's a long
time it's not like a 27y old and 29y old
like when it's huge when you're that kid
right I was the only one that I was
really cool with him everybody's like
but he I was the only was real cool with
him Dustin I mean they were all nice to
him but I'm saying that would like kind
of kick it with them or whatever but we
were little kids so there wasn't any you
know I just didn't realize cuz you know
when I'm tell these guys are
23 you know that's what that's what you
always imagine cuz they always get guys
are 25 playing 18s so you guys were
really 15 and that's what blows my mind
you're going to class and on set and go
I I have to go to class in real life
tomorrow yeah then I go to then I went
to chista high school I was the only one
that went to a big Public School
everybody else was either like priv
schooled or they went to like private
little kind of situations but I still
went to a public high school so I got to
you know wrestle for my team do plays
dance you know go to my what a sick
childhood prom and all that so yeah I
always say is like you know and we did
it in the summertime so I got to do that
because everybody was minor so they
didn't want to have to mess with school
most of the time we did in the
summertime so you're working all year
around you're going to school you never
even get your vacation you're going
straight to work yeah I
don't yeah no it was fun it wasn't like
fun and we saw you just posted up with
Zach Morris like two days ago right
picture so you guys are still friends
yeah yeah he's uh he's doing the bust
his balls a little bit yeah I always
break his balls first thing I thought I
know the homie for a long time he does
Jiu-Jitsu too so we'll train and stuff
oh so Tac Mor beat you up yeah well no
oh no not you not you I looked at Marty
when I said it yeah don't worry not you
yeah um but he's doing some show I
forget the name of it but it's on so I
had him on my show in Hollywood so you
know I was support and uh give him love
but yeah he he ironically lives in San
Diego now mhm so yeah so I see him we
had a fan question and I thought it was
too good not to ask and it said please
ask this if you could do a celebrity
boxing who are you
fighting I could ask that all the time
too do you really yeah but I mean I'd
really be boxing out there so it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be really fair
unless they had fought with that
experience cuz it's not like basketball
right you can get hurt um but um I would
only do it if uh my wife would kill me
cuz I promise I wouldn't do them but um
if it was like for charity or something
like that well you know what I want what
I really want to do and I'm hoping it it
happens because I'm a huge fan of his is
uh they're trying to get me and Tom
Hardy to do a Jiu-Jitsu match you know
and remember we and he he competes too
but he's one of my favorite actors and I
have mad respect for him for being such
a big star that he still goes out there
and competes I think it's awesome so it
would be an honor to like share the mat
with him um just as a fan be for I love
the dude he's awesome so it would be
great to like you know what I mean
something like that it'd be would' be a
lot of fun I'd be down for have you ever
role of Rogan or any like the comedians
no not Jo I know Joe but I haven't um
I'm going to Austin as a matter of fact
tomorrow uh coincidentally but um uh
comedians what comedians have I he got
the whole world and especially in comedy
everybody jiujitsu yeah yeah doing the
jiujitsu yeah no but I love that he um
is such a a mouthpiece for Jiu-Jitsu and
uh in MMA so yeah and he's obviously and
he has been since day one like Bravo
like turn the whole world on it right
right no exactly yeah so I and you know
I thought originally I was too old to
kind of get into it but I got my boys
into it um because they wouldn't take
him wrestling that young and when I got
him into it I'm like well maybe I should
just learn it so I can do it with them
and help them then I so I started doing
it like as a class to get into it and
I'm like oh [__] I still kind of got it
I still could to do this and then I
liked it I fell in love with it and so
then I started but if I didn't have sons
I probably wouldn't have gotten into it
to be honest with you just because I
thought I was too old which goes to
again show you're never too old to kind
of get into it cuz I assume like I don't
want to throw my back out I don't throw
my knees out I'm 37 like you're dud
you're a kid I know like but I just
assume that about training Jiu-Jitsu
like I've done the kickboxing and [__]
but I've never like that the kickboxing
and stuff in in boxing is much more
explosive no it's much more passive and
it's just a lot more squeezing and you
know what I mean and so no it's great
and um i' highly recommend what level
are you at with it I'm a purple belt at
the moment so I got brown belt coming up
and then you know and how many years
training has that been how many years
now
uh hold Dominic was six at least five
six or something but I had timeouts cuz
I was I still box so I had to take time
off when I got all my injuries so it do
you know what I'm saying every every
injury was like N9 months so when you're
when you're injured you're still you
have to actually work still yeah that
was the Emmys and Golden Gloves and [__]
with a sling the other one I had a boot
so all of them all of them yeah you can
Google all that [__] and you put it up I
got all injured on all those speaking of
the emies uh what was it the uh Golden
Globes the other day yeah and the emmies
and the emmies I keep seeing I can't
find it it keeps saying like uh Joe Koy
not hosting right made a bad jok or I
didn't see anything wrong with it as a
host did what did you see that people
are talking about I didn't see anything
wrong with it well first first of all I
know Joe is great guy and I've had him
on my show a lot and and he is and he's
very funny he was put in a tough
position because he only had I think
like a couple weeks to prepare and
you're talking about a room with the
biggest egos in the thinnest skin so
it's it's tough to kind of navigate I
didn't think the stuff he said was
offensive for because I watched it I
think yeah it's just that they made a
big deal about anything it's just like
you it's hard to joke these days man I
always say the two toughest things to be
right now are a policeman and a comic
cuz you just can't do your job you know
what I mean without people it's it's
it's tough so
you know like I I told him I said hey
bro you're going to have a lot of new
material now to go off on talking about
all that stuff but he's going to be just
fine and you know he's a cool dude do
you think he took that like horribly or
did he take like he understood what was
going on and wasn't well nobody likes to
hear any netive news about him but I
think I'm sure he understood the
situation but you know as as a as a
comic um it uh it provides for new fod
right yeah new material and stuff he
going start off his next speci with
there you go you guys watch the Golden
Gloves yeah
exactly clear the air it's going to be
those vibes on stage like this isn't
this audience is this isn't going well
um I'm trying to think no basically
trying to be
nice uh yeah you know fortunately I
don't I I don't think so there's some
audiences obviously a little more warm
than others but for the most part keep
it moving one question also are you an
only child no I have a sister Marisa she
lives in Houston she's got four kids um
she was a probation officer criminal law
criminal justice she and she married
some uh guy who's a NFL player and he's
a great guy and so no she's got a great
life she's living out there but there's
only two of us that's cuz my mom had
five brothers and five sisters and my
dad had four brothers and four sisters
so you know had a lot of cousins so you
know they end up having like raising
like the little so it was just like my
sister and I that was it m i I ask all
legends that come on the show if we
could look at like a lifetime Spotify
playlist watch list too most listen to
maybe top three artist lifetime what
would that look like for you music wise
you know I'm a big music lover and I
love all music
from hip-hop R&B soul to to to
Mariachi Ree and uh even Hard Rock I
mean I really do I love it I I love it
all shuffle playlist there like that
Meme that goes around you know with like
Chalino and easy and [__] that that's me
you know what I mean every single
Shuffle like well it depends like if I'm
training so when I train in Jiu-Jitsu
for example um I always put put on U
sort of house music cuz I like the I
like the meat to keep going cuz you're
as you're moving when I go to the when I
go to the boxing gyms it depends with
gym hip-hop's always playing if I'll go
to the one um here in Hollywood when I
go to the one in eastlos it's always
Mariachis or something you know what I
mean it's playing there when I'm in the
car if my uh wife's in it she likes to
listen to like her pulse kind of you
know like soft rock kind of stuff
whatever and uh when of my kids it's all
pop and kind of my daughter's actually
really into sizzor right now so that so
it depends and I appreciate them all and
uh and I like them all to be honest all
right so one question I ask everybody
I'm surprised I haven't done yet what
are your besides no comedies what are
your favorite three movies ever it's
hard well it's hard dude you got to go
like in the genres for me and also no
comedies no comedies that's that's
impossible I feel yeah you're right
comedies are probably a b because it's
like oh today I feel like watching
anchor man but tomorrow I'm going to
watch I don't know stford son yeah yeah
yeah well yeah well that's a show yeah I
know I know what you I got it this
morning my bock me I think it'd be
easier to say what movie have you seen
the most cuz that's what I always ask
permission to use that pretty
good but what movie have you seen the
most it's always hard to favor like
favorite actor you worked with your
favorite movie the one I've seen the
most is probably good Fellas to be
honest I quote it all the time and I got
a buddy toty that we call from the movie
right there probably good Fellas and I
grew up in that era right the Good
Fellas Scarface Godfather era and every
year my dad and I uh watch The Godfather
Saga when during Christmas 10 10 hours
every every Christmas every now my
wife's Italian too so now we for sure we
watching it thrs you down so they're
probably the ones that I watched the
most like we threw on heat the other day
too I love heat so lot ofo as I say it
out loud right there um my dad wanted to
see the deer hunter which is an old
school din movie which is really good
too so um yeah those are probably the
ones I've watched the most to be honest
but I'm also a big CL Ewood fan I like
westerns on I love w W Unforgiven is
probably one of my favorite movies I've
seen Unforgiven a lot my favorite
Western is Outlaw Josie Wales it's a
badass Western you never seen it un no
he named his dog
Josie favorite movie I love watch 150
times man the good the bad the ugly
little ugly Mexican dude I don't even
think he's not Mexican that's say he's
not even Mexican no he's not that's what
I say like as an old man like that's a
white guy what is he it's the same old
man from the next westerns 40 years
later I thought going back going back to
that like he wasn't even he just gave
him a little thin and go hey fo your T
him up yeah they did all those fools are
supposed to be Puerto Rican and Westside
Story none of those fools Puerto Rican
they put some dark ass makeup on them
and they a white dudes playing right
there well on the original the original
yeah the original one I got to watch it
again The Westerns mom movies all that
stuff I grew up really loving all right
Outlaw Jos that's funny that's my
uncle's favorite movie yeah Outlaw J is
my favorite Western for sure oh favorite
okay so um I think Goodfellas is the
number one movie that we've ever had
every guest we once or twice a month cuz
I I have to ask every person just yeah
cuz that's like I mean that's like when
I grew up right so like uh in high
school coming up and stuff I'm sure you
scar faces and stuff too so constantly
it was it was it's heat Good Fellas and
uh Casino Casino too great Bronx tail
one of my favorite Bronx tail too Cal my
son's name is sunny but uh Santino based
off The Godfather we call him Sunny
really yeah yeah all right so my mom
name my brother God so um so I I'm not
sure I mean your access Hol we talk
about it often like man that's that's
what you got to be like appeal to
everybody but I want to ask a question
we we're going to smoke you out because
you're Mario Lopez not going to do that
in the world when he walked in here with
blazing in here we haven't at all
because like I don't want to smoke them
out it's just the smell of the
building it's a bunch of there's so much
weed everywhere sorry but what is your
relationship with we have you ever
spoked is is that's just a question see
I cannot talk about
this ask corporate right here I cannot
participate in such activities gentlemen
so you know uh see that's why we kept it
look at there's not even an ash in no
but like if you did I'm not one to you
got to do can't do it can't do it to you
man yeah yeah every person leaves I'm
clean I don't drink I
don't I eat raw you know what I mean so
the whole thing yeah know I'm a proud uh
corporate guys I got to uh you know keep
a PC see with Tony Haw about signed to
Disney huh can't even be around this so
that's why we we just wanted to make
sure because when people get here like I
have to smoke like no didn't smoke
before you people we don't expect get
real aggressive with the show too yes
agressive with like they like yo let me
smoke that I'm like really challenging
Thomas and show yeah I know what random
it's just like will will sass is one of
our favorite favorite guys I'm like hey
are cool we smoke like can I have one
like oh my God my heart so excited but
yeah this is the this is we smoke a jent
it's not the weed show but it might be
no do what you got to do and hey it's
legal it's all good no it's all good
it's just uh you know for you I said I'm
trying to be the Latino di clerk I got
to keep a clean cut so fluffy at least
on camera I got to keep it clean cut all
right um so the last thing I want to ask
uh because you were talking about I
don't know who these fools are talking
about me not being Mexican and [__] I
saw a couple years ago this it was like
on all over social media no it was how
you tripping like I my name is Mario
yeah I would it was you eating it was
you doing your uh your your food your
food uh videos oh yeah well that's the
thing about social media so you peeled
back a little bit well it's it's it's
social media when you're putting it out
there is sort of a behind the scenes
look at yeah how you are or how you
really are and what you're put putting
out there right so when I'm on Access
Hollywood and I'm in millions of homes
all over and my average viewer is the
55-year-old housewife I'm going to keep
be keep it buttoned up up and have my
customer service voice M right and hey
welcome to Access Hollywood Mario Lopez
professional host but when I'm going to
go eat myos with my friends then I'm
like a you better get the BOS I got
those last time that [__] was bomb you
know what I mean then I'm being myself
then I'm being myself so I can't be that
guy and I wouldn't want to be that guy
on TV do that make sense you're like oh
you're not being yourself like I am
being myself there just why you got why
you know I'm a chameleon I'm going to be
I'm I'm going to act you act different
in front of your mom than you do with
your friend I'm going to act different
on TV than I am with let's say my wife
yeah you know what I'm saying or my girl
or whatever the case may be right you're
going to be different around your kids
than you are you wear different hats in
life it's a very ignorant way to think
totally you know yeah and then they
wouldn't want to say that on my face cuz
they wouldn't want to smoke either so
that's I'm saying you know I'm saying so
you know it's a very ignorant way to
think and you're you're limiting yeah
your potential your Viewpoint and
hurting us as a people because we should
be able to rise above
and play to the highest common
denominator and not dumb ourselves down
to a society yeah most those fools
aren't even as freaking Hood as like you
know what I'm saying they don't know
what it is but I'm smart enough to
realize that hey yeah I'm smart enough
to realize like hey you gotta you got to
be out there and look at yourself and
like di Clark said as a brand and as a
commodity to appeal to everyone do not
limit yourself cuz you're short changing
yourself I'm trying to cash those checks
everywhere I don't want just be in one
have it in one Revenue stream trying to
host Oscars one you know what I'm saying
you know so that's what I'm saying so
any like young Latino kids out there you
can keep it real and you can do what you
want and have different but hey be smart
enough to know keep it buttoned up man
keep it not you want to make real money
get that corporate money you know so
that's if
I hopefully in 5 years might play this
clip see that's why yeah I love that
every every guest we try to take
something away and keep store something
this is this is my favorite thing to do
I'm learning the whole time that's
that's my my parting words as I got to
go pick up my kid go pick up my kid no
thank you so much for being here but
also Mario Lopez across everything
pardon me Mario Lopez on all social
medias right yes Mario Lopez he's IG
Instagram on Tik Tok and yeah yeah you
got hell memes going on Twitter I was
yeah oh you like that
yeah but thank you so much I TR stoked
man appreciate you um yeah we're just
talking you guys for for Marty uh Mario
Lopez and I have a dope ass
[Music]
day
perfect
[Music]